Archer burst onto the scene in 2009
phrasing winning a loyal FX audience and
rave reviews from critics
Adam reads spy spoof mixed James Bond
with The Simpsons and the Quickfire bite
of Arrested Development with the time
hopping eighth season going full on film
noir it's a perfect time to head into
the danger zone and reveal some facts
you may not have known about Archer the
ghost behind the spy way back in 1994
Cartoon Network took a chance on an
insane idea a cartoon talk show hosted
by a throwaway superhero from the 1960s
that's what gave birth to space ghost
coast to coast
that was the show that eventually
spawned the insanity of the Adult Swim
programming block which has since become
a cultural force on television but it
also led to the insanity of Archer many
years later this is about conducting
espionage operations for years with no
authority or permission whatsoever from
the United States government Mother
Archer showrunner Adam Reed got his
start working on Space Ghost as a writer
during seasons four through six Reed
then got to make his own show Sealab
2021
a parody straight out of the Space Ghost
school of spoofing hanna-barbera
cartoons the original 1972 show was
Sealab 2020 an animated series set in
the then distant future where scientists
lived under the sea ends that's all
anyone remembers because the show lasted
less than three months reads parody had
a longer life and for good reason it was
hilarious and very Archer who needs
x-ray vision they'll beg to show that
and am i robot all that spoofing of 60s
and 70s cartoons sharpen reads comic
voice leading to Archer and thus a
legend was born let's be real Reed an
executive producer Matt Thompson used
the real-life faces of friends
acquaintances and industry pros from
their home base of Atlanta to create the
look of many archer characters as
vulture reported in 2013 Malory Archer
is based on Atlanta actress and Jessica
Walter doppelganger Kathleen Cohen
sterling Archer comes from model Jason
Fitzgerald's Atlanta
antiques dealer candy McHale Hannon is
the face of Pam and Kenyetta Lester a
Hooters waitress Reid met after a
monster truck rally serves as the model
for Lana while chris parnell looks a lot
like the character he voices cyril he's
actually not the model instead the
animators turned to Atlanta
restaurateurs Stewart Fierman for
inspiration then there's lucky Yates he
voices Krieger but he's actually the
facial inspiration for Rey who's in turn
played by show creator Adam Reed
confusing enough what are we thinking
what are we doing what are we wearing
Crysis best mr. fat face as for Krieger
his face belongs to Ben Brieger Reid's
former college classmate which is how
Krieger got his name rigged or
volunteered his real name but Reid
altered it slightly to give the man some
dignity well at least you got some
closure oh you're just your mother all
over
Lucky's early years speaking of lucky
Yates the voice behind archers mad
scientist Krieger his first high-profile
acting gig was on the Food Network it's
true Yates played a wide variety of
characters on Alton Brown's wacky
cooking show good eats
including a fishmonger a butcher and the
infamous dungeon master master I want
you to dose the moat in a reddit ask me
anything
Yates had nothing but praise for Brown
saying the famous foodie is even more
hilarious in real life crossing the line
Archer is undeniably edgy its violent
sexually explicit and unafraid to poke
fun at well just about everything nice
job Oliver Cromwell but believe it or
not some scenarios are forbidden even on
Archer according to showrunner Adam Reed
one script had Archer disarming a
terrorist by throwing his baby boy
Sheamus at him this didn't sit well with
the folks at FX who told Reid we're not
a network that throws babies a bold
stance it wasn't the only time FX put up
a fight in season two a young German
girl hits on Archer and in the original
script she was only 14
FX said that was not okay
eventually the two sides came to an
agreement settling for 16 amazingly the
age issue actually made it onto the show
I am from Germany there the age of
consent is 40 what is it the Alabama of
Europe in many ways yes Archer imitating
life in season four Malory Archer
married a car dealership owner named Ron
Cadillac much to the chagrin of sterling
Archer cadillac is voiced by Ron Liebman
who is not only Rachel's Awful's add on
friends why would you bring me sewage
but is also actually married to Jessica
Walter who voices Mallory the thespian
couple has been hitched since 1983 and
were both known more for their dramatic
work until late into their careers I
don't know how to ask Malory Archer
would never stand for that Kriegers
codes when it comes to hidden jokes and
messages Archer is nearly unmatched take
for example the elaborate Easter Egg
leading fans to Krieger secret website
it's complicated but here's the gist in
season six there's a brief shot of
serial numbers associated with the
character Conway Stern if you plug that
number into something called a hex code
translator you get the address for a
YouTube video from there you have to
fall far down the rabbit hole to get to
Krieger sites including translating the
sound in the YouTube clip into an
additional code then using that code to
make your way to a fake Craigslist ad
crack some more codes and on and on once
you arrive the username and password is
hilariously Krieger and guests once
you're logged in you can play games view
images and download Kriegers actual in
show ringtone teutonic but I tried Cyril
Pam Cheryl now I'm even trying Krieger
where the hell is everybody it's a
fitting thoroughly bonkers tribute to a
thoroughly bonkers character ed thanks
for watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love too
[Music]